I often get emails that say David is the
modern Republican party now fascist is
fascism what they would employ if there
were no barriers or opposition or
obstacles so let's explore this a little
bit and think it through and where I end
up coming down is that the modern
Republican Party
is a fascistic authoritarian party but
not actually fascist but part of the
reason why they are not actually fascist
is that there is opposition in the
United States so let's start with the
definition what are we talking about
when we talk about fascism fascism is a
far right
authoritarian political ideology which
often includes dictatorial power
forcible suppression of opposition and
very strongly regimented society and a
very strongly regimented economy now
some of these things might not sound
like the rhetoric of the Republican
party with strong regimentation the
Republican party is all about freedom
and liberty yes the rhetoric is but are
they actually like that when it comes to
policy so we're going to talk about that
what is the Republican Party platform
and policy
versus fascism or fascistic
authoritarianism because it is true that
it used to be the case that the
Republican party was known for
conservative values actually being for
small government promoting truly free
market capitalism or something close to
it but that is not at all what the
modern report modern Republican party
particularly under Mega trumpism has
become it has become a party of
hypernationalism
populist rhetoric
as well as extraordinarily overbearing
suppression of opposition all fascistic
characteristics and the bulk of this the
culmination of it has been seen in the
shift during the rise of Donald Trump
and his influence on the Republican
Party the rhetoric of trump and the
policies that trumpists would like to
implement are every combination of
authoritarian sometimes xenophobic
anti-competitive
Etc and we're going to look at a bunch
of examples the Muslim ban
family separation at the border trying
to overturn the 2020 presidential
election results trying to limit the
speech of the press and trying to get
adversarial reporters banned including
Jim Acosta Etc in addition to this
the attempt to suppress opposition
through election
meddling tactics that disproportionately
affect young people people of color
low-income individuals
disproportionately those who vote on the
left is another way in which Republicans
under Maga have tried to hold on to
Power by any means necessary even when
they've been voted out completely
anti-democratically now there are people
who will argue these are straight up
fascist tactics others say it's kind of
too extreme a term but it is very hard
to argue that it isn't fascistic and
Hardline authoritarianism the actions
and the rhetoric of Mega trumpism aka
the modern Republican party have taken
that bent so let's talk about some of
the specific policies and there are so
many but let's talk about a few the
Muslim ban one of the first things that
Donald Trump did as president
was signed an executive order Banning
travel from several Muslim majority
countries
it was done under the guise of
protecting the United States but it
targeted
muslim-majority countries that had not
actually been the sources of terrorism
to the United States you could make the
case that either way it was fascistic
but particularly when you're not even
targeting the quote right countries
based on what you claim to want to
achieve
discriminatory and absolutely
authoritarian so scale up of the
separation of families at the border the
zero tolerance policy at the southern
border which resulted in the separation
of families and the Detention of
children in cages inhumane cruel
emblematic of fascistic authoritarianism
the attacks on media Trump calling the
media fake news Trump's saying you can't
believe what you are hearing and seeing
you've got to listen to me to know the
truth enemy of the people get Jim Acosta
out of the White House Press briefing
room get adversarial media shut down
etc etc undermining Free Press which is
a Cornerstone of democracy voter
suppression
um pushing for uh voter ID of the kind
that would just make it harder for
people to vote uh shortening early
voting hours pushing for all of these
different things while claiming they are
trying to steal and cheat and Rob an
election
extraordinarily fascistic militarizing
the police Trump supported the use of
military equipment by police under the
guise of Law and Order
and that was an open attempt to suppress
dissident
protesters and those with views
adversarial to Trump embracing
authoritarian and dictatorial leaders
right I mean listen when you criticize
Canada and France and Germany Democratic
countries and you go I don't know I
believe Putin no matter what he says and
Kim Jong-un and I wrote each other love
letters and duterte has been very strong
on drugs and she does quick trials and
the death penalty for drug dealers and
bolsonaro and erdogan and Orban this is
another authoritarian fascistic Slide
the entire attempt to steal an election
Trump didn't win of course straight out
of the dictator's Playbook and then
lastly I would also point to
hardcore attempts to control private
private businesses for your personal
political gain and I'm thinking of big
Tech and social media
we don't want to uh we don't want to
regulate businesses unless it's
absolutely necessary businesses should
be allowed to regulate themselves and do
what they want except when we want to
force Twitter to publish Trump's
election lies covet this information and
on and on so bottom line
the modern Republican party may not fit
all of the characteristics of fascist
ideology and we certainly are not living
under fascism in the United States and
we weren't when Trump was President
either but there are elements of extreme
authoritarianism nationalism
right-wing populist rhetoric used to
justify some pretty hardcore policy and
it should concern all of us who worry
about this fascistic direction to the
American Republican party fascism no not
yet fascistic authoritarianism with some
dictatorial dreams 100 percent
let's talk about something else many
have written to me about
what the hell happened to the alt-right
where did they go are they still around
at the start of Trump's presidency
everything was alt right we are the
alt-right they are the alt-right both
self-professed and discussed in media in
policy circles Etc
rarely if ever do we hear about the
alt-right today so what happened to it
did it go the way of the Tea Party
partially destroyed partially integrated
into the modern Republican party has
Maga trumpism essentially absorbed the
alt-right well let's talk about it in
the early 2010s
as the Tea Party had gotten their wins
and then started to fade that happened
in 2010 so then you go to 2013 2014.
this new political movement emerged in
the United States which was ultimately
known as the alt-right Loosely defined
group of individuals rejected mainstream
conservatism dabbled in white
nationalism dabbled in anti-Semitism
dabbled in uh xenophobia and all sorts
of other far-right ideologies and as the
2016 presidential election got going and
Donald Trump ultimately won the
nomination of the Republican party and
became a general election candidate and
won 2015 2016-2017 we saw the alt-right
gain significant prominence
since then though
the alt-right as such has significantly
faded out of public eye
why did this happen there's a number of
things that are going on important to
identify to understand the continued
evolution of Mega trumpism number one
the alt-right as such started to get hit
with significant backlash from media
from the left and from mainstream
conservatives as well people like you
know Mitt Romney kinzinger Etc who
distanced themselves from the movement
and condemned its extremist views they
saw that under trumpism it was
continuing to grow and that it wasn't a
good thing as far as they were concerned
secondly many of the alt-right leaders
ended up exposed they were exposed as
really just being racist really just
being anti-semitic really just being
xenophobic and so many of the alt-right
leaders lost credibility and they lost
support and some of them ended up kind
of dissolving into Mega trumpism
uh third we saw Mega trumpism
accept and absorb
some elements of alt-right ideology uh
certainly the cultish loyalty to Donald
Trump uh the rejection of establishment
politics embracing populist rhetoric
which you then fill in with right-wing
policy prescriptions when it comes to it
and so Mega trumpism I mean listen I'm
trying to be fair and charitable here
there are of course elements of
anti-Semitism and white nationalism and
megatropism without a doubt I don't
believe Trump created them but he
coalesced them and he welcomed them in
the mega trumpism what I'm trying to be
accurate but also not weak in it Mega
trumpism was less overtly anti-semitic
and homophobic and whatever else the
case may be than the alt-right and thus
has achieved some success by kind of
integrating some of those alt-right
elements into it one big difference
between the alt-right and mega trumpism
is that Mega trumpism has succeeded in
part because they have this charismatic
to some degree cult-like leader in Trump
whereas the alt-right never really had
that leader they had a bunch of
different people who led different
aspects of it Richard Spencer maybe
Gavin McGinnis and I know I'm forgetting
a bunch of others but they didn't have
Trump and so Trump's presence was a big
factor in mega trumpism superseding the
alt-right so bottom line the alt-right
as such has indeed greatly faded from
public View
its views haven't gone away and it has a
legacy inside of Mega trumpism the
question we are now left with is will it
survive another election cycle or will
the boberts and the Marjorie Taylor
greens and Trump himself
suffer a 2024 defeat that could be the
final nail in the coffin for this
roughly decade period is what it will be
at the end of the day eight years ten
years roughly 11 years depending on when
you consider the start of alt-right will
alt-right die
as part of Mega trumpism in 2024 that's
the question that remains to be answered
and one we're going to continue asking
we'll take a quick break make sure you
are subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show
pushing very strongly towards two
million subscribers
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David packman show continues to be
an audience supported program I invite
you I implore you am I begging no I'm
stopping short of begging but I will say
please clap no in all seriousness uh if
you do want to support the work that we
do you can go to joinpakman.com but we
have too much to talk about today for me
to spend too much more time on that all
right let's hear from some people in the
audience I want to start today with Josh
from Delaware we take calls via Discord
at davidpackman.com Discord Josh welcome
what is on your mind today
hey David can you hear me yes I can
awesome uh first time caller glad to be
here
um yeah so definitely wanted to talk
about last week
um I know one of the big things that
gets talked about a lot of is the
election lies
um and you know I do have some friends
that uh always talk about a legend was
stolen it was stolen there's so much
evidence but where is the evidence
um just kind of I wanted to hear from
you on uh has anyone ever sent you
anything just showcasing any evidence of
electric fraud at all no I mean many
people all the way up to Mike pillow
have said as soon as we get off this
interview I'm going to send you all the
evidence from my cyber guys or whatever
they've never sent any evidence at all
sometimes they will send me a link to
that Dinesh D'Souza Movie 2000 mules but
of course even that doesn't have any
evidence it just has video of people
dropping off ballots at dropboxes with
ominous music playing and some
geolocation data that doesn't actually
prove anything and you know the I I'm
willing to work forwards which is show
me the evidence from which I can draw a
conclusion if and if the conclusion is
that the election was stolen by Joe
Biden I will tell you after this many
years of claims with no evidence I'm
starting to wonder whether maybe the
evidence doesn't exist Josh
thank you David and I have one more
follow-up question pretty quick
um but Fox News
um you know I know one of the other
things has always been the uh pretty
recently the text messages that were
sent privately between the Fox News host
especially with Tucker Carlson yeah
kind of your thoughts on that
how can people still watch Fox News
after that information was released and
I also got to say I don't remember
Tucker even denouncing that uh those
messages weren't even him so how can
people still watch Fox News and uh
believe that's still a good news
organization to get their uh get their
daily news from primarily the answer is
that Tucker's viewers either will never
hear about the text messages in which
Tucker says he despises Trump or they
will explain it away by saying well
Tucker had to say that for this reason
or that reason but he didn't really mean
it or they will say he has since changed
his mind they'll explain it away one way
or the other they seem pretty committed
at this point to Tucker into Fox News
got it well thanks David appreciate your
time and hope you have a good rest your
day pleasure there is Josh from Delaware
very very much appreciate that remember
to ideally get right to your question
and I love that everybody's got their
correct audio devices selected today
let's go to Carolyn from Utah Carolyn
from Utah welcome to the David packman
show what's on your mind today what can
I do for you
Carolyn from Utah you've been invited to
join welcome can you hear me yes I can
okay great
um I've been a long time listener now
this is a question okay I'm from Utah
like I like you said um we have a
Republican Governor um box who's more of
a Midstream mainstream Republican he's
not too far to the left or too far to
the right but um he had uh
nominated a democratic person to go to
our environmental Council or whatever
and um the Republican
the people who would approve this
nomination of course put it down they
said no she can't be on the committee
now my question has to do with
um
the fact that the Republicans for so
long
let this information rule in regards to
climate change and things like that and
um in particular the way the Democrats
Act
so now some of these mainstream
Republicans
are trying to of course make a
turnaround
and when they realized they went too far
is there any way that you think that
they can pull back
the Republican Party short of I don't
know I I'm worried about the Civil War
thing but sort of civil war is there any
way that we can pull back
the people that are
so far gone they can't understand reason
and logic so Carolyn I apologize a lot
of the first stuff you said I did not
Carolyn a lot of the first stuff you
said I didn't really understand and you
also had a couple of audio glitches in
there but but what I think you're asking
me is is there any way to pull extremist
Republicans who are in in Fantasyland
kind of back to reality is that
generally your question
yeah but um in particular if there's any
way well for the mainstream Republicans
to do it I don't think we have any
chance oh okay I think the best shot
that mainstream Republicans to the
extent that they still exist have to
pull the extremists back to to reality
is by proving to them really showing
them that if you guys are are the
direction the party goes we lose I think
that that's the only way and even then I
think that if the Maga extremist Wing
just started losing badly I don't even
know that you would convert a lot of
those people I think a lot of those
people would give up and leave politics
so it's it's not it might not even
really be a conversion but I do think
that it's possible not with all of these
people but with some if Republicans
start taking more and more and more
losses as they already have but even
more
and then the mainstream Republicans say
it's because of you we need to come back
to something more approximating like
Mitt Romney or John McCain I think that
that's their best shot and even that may
not work I don't know
yeah that would be um great so
I I know there's been a lot of Articles
lately about Civil War and everything
what do you think our chances are of
ending up in something like that as of
right now so I never like to make these
long-term predictions the US will never
have a civil war we just don't know the
way I would assess it is I see the
chance of a civil war over the next five
years as extremely close to zero not
zero but extremely close to zero over
the next five years that's kind of where
I'm comfortable going right now
okay all right well thank you so much
for taking my call Pleasure Carolyn from
Utah great to hear from you why don't we
go next to A Treatise from Boston uh
treaties from Boston welcome back to the
program how's it going
hey David good to talk to you again
likewise I have a quick question I
remember a few months ago we briefly
talked about
um ranked Choice voting yes and I can
remember three four years ago it not
being a very well-known system but after
Alaska adopted it and it's at least
blamed on Sarah Palin losing I'm
wondering if do you think that with
things like that like it
being aiding in a Democrat winning or at
least you know blaming it uh with Sarah
Palin's loss and things like that do you
think that it'll kind of its progress in
being adopted Nationwide will be
stagnated uh just kind of by these
right-wing talking points of that it's
uh just a tool by the left to uh you
know cheerleading with the majority of
that sort of thing I don't think it will
help and it's sort of similar to
movements to move from an electoral
college system to a national popular
vote are limited by a number of
different factors but many Republicans
are aware that we're not for the
electoral vote if we had a national
popular vote there's a whole bunch of
their winners who would have actually
lost so it is without question that at
least the Republicans that pay attention
know that popular vote isn't great for
them the extent to which they know that
that uh transferable voter ranked Choice
voting is bad for them I I think it's
less clear but I do think that the Sarah
Palin situation in Alaska is a
cautionary tale you know the truth is in
the midst of all the insanity of the
last year it hasn't been a topic
anyone's been talking about too much so
it actually could be an opportunity to
make some progress on ranked Choice
voting uh for dedicated activists
yeah I would say like definitely now
well it's not as in the mainstream I I
think it kind of was within like the few
months before the midterms but after all
that it kind of got lost in the shuffle
I agree I do have one other quick that
thank you for that I do have one quick
follow-up question do you have a
favorite political movie
not really I mean I think uh as far as a
documentary I actually forget the name
of it but it's a documentary from when
Paul bagala and James Carville ran Bill
Clinton's campaign uh
is it called the war room now I don't
remember it's a it's a good documentary
I don't really watch too many political
movies to be honest
uh yeah I mean this one in ten are of
quality uh but fair thank you so much
for taking my call all right a treaties
from Boston great to hear from you again
why don't we go next to Thomas from New
York Thomas from New York welcome to the
David Pacman show
hey David how's it going going well
all right so um I'm sure you know
obviously that Donald Trump got you last
week and that may or may not affect
Trump's run for president but yes um I
may just want to ask about Ron DeSantis
uh some people say that Ron DeSantis is
more of a threat to democracy than
Donald Trump is through the multiple
bills he assigned in Florida so just
don't say give gay bill and his bills
are uh to affect elections my question
is is if you agree with the sentiment
that Ron DeSantis is more dangerous to
the sanctity of democracy if he would
become president rather than Donald
Trump Post January 6 and his arrest
I generally believe so this this is the
way I kind of frame it if you said to me
today
either Trump or DeSantis will be
president for four years I think I see
DeSantis as the greater threat and would
say if those are my choices I would
rather Trump be president four years
rather than DeSantis DeSantis seems much
more focused whereas Trump's brain is
kind of all over the place DeSantis is
likely to be more effective at actually
making horrible
legislative accomplishments whereas
again Trump gets so distracted and
embroiled in controversy that I think he
would be less effective the Counterpoint
to all of this is that on the world
stage Trump is so cartoonish and such a
joke that it might damage American
reputation more to see Trump president
for another four years than DeSantis so
it's sort of like DeSantis would make
our reputation not quite as bad but he
would do far more damage now there's
another layer to this which you didn't
directly ask about but I think is also
important
in the polling right now there's Trump
versus Biden polling and DeSantis versus
Biden polling Biden does better against
Trump than against DeSantis so that
would be another reason to want Trump as
the nominee rather than DeSantis because
it seems it's more likely to lead to a
Democratic president winning in 2024 but
again this is all very early polling
data
yeah I think Trump is definitely is a
lot more cares about his ego so he will
be less he kind of doesn't get LED as
much by the Republicans I think Ron
DeSantis is a lot smarter and a lot more
nefarious in that way I think that's
true thank you I appreciate the the
answer my pleasure Thomas from New York
uh great to hear from you uh got right
to his question I mean really a perfect
phone call Audio was good just a good
call in really every way we are taking
calls via Discord davidpackman.com
Discord just a reminder if you want to
get on your nickname uh must be your
name and where you're calling from or
where you're calling from and your name
you know just names alone or nicknames
or sorts stuff like that is not likely
to get you on let's go to Rodney from St
Louis Rodney from St Louis welcome to
the program
hey David can you hear me yes I can
okay great uh first of all I want to say
congratulations on last week or week and
a half ago when you had the right wing
attacking you and uh your audience was
able to Rally we made it we made it
Rodney I appreciate that
yeah it was amazing just got me thinking
that uh obviously the number one thing
that we all run into on every single
issue is the money-powered interest yes
and every single time the media doesn't
ever cover it and it's not really
covered that much even on Independent
Media but I would think if maybe I don't
know if you and like Sam and Jack or tyt
and others on the left ever get together
and like try to like use your audiences
to strategically get the word out or
even acknowledge that the left media is
even existing yeah you know we really
don't and we should the last time I saw
Jenkins Sam was like in the same place I
saw Sam more recently but the last time
the three of us were in the same place
was at a conference in Vegas like right
before the pandemic and I'll be honest
this this particular issue did not come
up it was really kind of a social thing
we went to dinner but I actually do
think you know one of the things I've
talked about before and I think you're
kind of getting at this Rodney is that
when it come to funding Independent
Media and creating this sort of like
under
belly sounds negative but in a sense
it's an underbelly it's a layer we might
call it of a media to really try to get
young people to come to our side right
when they leave College
the right funds that to an insane degree
I mean I I recently heard I don't know
if this is true that Turning Point USA
raised like 40 million dollars or
something like that and the right has
way more of these right-wing think tanks
whether when you join you're much better
paid than if you're on the left then you
join like whatever the left-wing
equivalent would be
so I actually think there would be a lot
of value it doesn't have to be you know
me along with Jenkins Sam but somebody
and I'm willing to be a part of it and
obviously Jenkins Sam would be great
people to have involved as well we need
to just make really clear like listen to
some degree like there's not actually a
mystery about what's going on here we're
winning on so many of the issues when
you ask people to review on abortion
their view on gay marriage The View on
using taxes all these different things
it's like it's very clear the left is
winning on the issues but we simply
aren't doing what we need to do in terms
of funding the messaging and the right
crushes us on this and for all the talk
about George Soros George Soros has
never funded me or any of the people you
mentioned and and it is something where
if the left is ghosting you guys they're
ghosting a hundred percent yeah like I
mean 100 when's the last time you've
seen AOC or Bernie talk about David
packman or tyt or the majority report
that 100 that needs to happen 100 this
spark has to happen yeah and I think we
need to have more advocates in Congress
address and and we do have some you know
rocon is a big Advocate and I think to
some degree like Eric swalwell and I can
certainly name people but Europe this is
a huge systemic problem it's bigger than
me Jenkins Sam but to the extent I can
be a part of solving it I'm glad to be
yeah you guys are just in my wheelhouse
yeah you know I agree with 99 of what
you guys you know talk about and I love
it are you good to do a great job thanks
so much Rodney great great call and
great topic
thank you all right there goes Rodney
let's take just a very quick break just
to let cooler heads prevail no I'm
kidding we just need a quick break if
you're still wanting to talk to me just
hold on because we're coming right back
to the phones after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more people in the audience
how about Ramiro from Indiana welcome
back to the program sir
Ramiro please accept my invitation to
join the program there he is
there sorry about that no problem so uh
my quick question is uh so Donald Trump
everything going on obviously we know
um there's nothing in place that would
prevent him from running for president
even from prison correct that's that's
my understanding yeah
so
um is that is there a reason for is it
simply because there isn't a specific
law in the books for that or is it a
conscious effort to say prevent
something like uh let's for example if
Donald Trump well when he won in 2016
let's say 2020 he was running against
Hillary again and he was afraid that she
would beat him so like he would jail his
political prisoner like saying lock her
up
in an attempt to
I guess so is that the reason something
like that a law preventing that from
happening is it in place that's a good
question which is is the reason why
you're allowed to run for president from
prison that it prevents someone from
jailing a political opponent to get them
out of a race yeah so that's not my
understanding of the reasoning why I I
think the reasoning is a lot kind of
less less uh um uh exciting which is the
principle of law that if something isn't
banned then it's allowed and since
nothing expressly bans someone from
being in prison and running for
president it's allowed we've never
really had a situation in which I think
someone would actually have a shot at
winning the way Trump would but I'll be
honest Romero it's a very interesting
question I don't think it's going to
play out in any real way because I don't
think Trump's going to be in prison no
and I don't either yeah I don't either
but um I guess I wanted to know your
opinion do you think that that loss
should be in place or like I said do you
think it shouldn't be in place to
possibly prevent something like a
bolsonaro trying to jail Lula de Silva
and all that stuff generally speaking
generally speaking I'm okay with the
requirements to be president being super
super basic now remember I'm not allowed
to run for president because I wasn't
born in the United States I could make
the argument actually that should be
changed but forget about me I'm not even
arguing just in general you know age
natural born citizen okay I actually
think that I don't want to be putting a
whole bunch of new requirements on
although I am obviously ideologically uh
interested in the idea of some kind of
compass competency test which might have
ruled out Donald Trump but the one thing
that's a little crazy for me is if in
some states if you're a felon you can't
vote but yet you could be a convicted
felon and people vote for you and you
win something about that seems a little
incongruous you know it's weird
yeah yeah that's funny and that's why I
asked the question because if you would
have asked me before 2016 yeah I would
have said yeah no you should absolutely
not be able to run for president if
you're in jail but then I got to
thinking I'm like right we you know was
him running his campaign screaming lock
her up lock her up and I got to thinking
you know maybe that's maybe it's a good
thing that that's not on the books but
it is funny that you can be in prison
and not be allowed to vote after you get
out it's yeah yeah there's a lot of
these weird incongruous things but it's
I think the point we both Come Away with
is the next 18 months are going to be
pretty insane
yeah absolutely all right my friend
thank you for the call appreciate it
there's uh Ramiro from Indiana why don't
we go next to Casey from Kansas Casey
from Kansas welcome back to the program
hello
yeah I just have a simple question this
time since I think you already covered
it a little bit on your show
uh do you think what the win of Brandon
Johnson in Chicago against his more
tough on crime more police
endorsed by the Fraternal Order
candidate do you think that could make
Democrats like Joe Biden rethink their
tough on crime pivot
maybe you know go to a more solve it
from The Roots type of thing
why would so you're saying the fact that
Brandon Johnson won with his we're gonna
reform but support police sort of
mentality would that make Biden change
his mind about his approach why would it
make Biden change his mind
well I mean Biden has seemed like he's
going for a more traditional tough on
crime type of thing
oh I see at least you know why I don't
think that would really influence Biden
much what makes sense politically at the
city level is different than what makes
sense at the state level and certainly
for running as as a presidential
campaign so I don't think Biden would be
moved much by what worked in Chicago for
a mayoral race
what about like other you know City
Democrats like Eric Adams or somebody
like that that may be that may be that
it could although all of these Mayors
often think and it might be true that
their City's circumstances are different
than others and so they really shouldn't
go by what other Mayors do it's just a
kind of a general thought that often is
in mayor's Minds
okay well I guarantee you that if the
opposite had happened and if Paul vales
had one that people like Eric Adams
would be shouting from the rooftops like
this is proof that yeah Democrats need
to get more tough on crime we need
harsher you know charges for felons and
everything like that you're probably
right you're probably right as far as
that goes yeah no but I don't expect to
see Biden adjust much as a on the basis
of what happened in Chicago to answer
the first question
yeah well I wish he would but yeah I
guess he'll probably continue as he's
going into 2024. I believe so Casey from
Kansas always great to hear from you
okay thank you all right there he goes
why don't we go next to Ronald from
Illinois speaking of Illinois let's go
to Ronald from Illinois welcome to the
program
hey David can you hear me yeah
hey I'm at work baby but I just got a
quick question for you so last week
Trump got arrested why has Biden been so
quiet about her I actually like it I
think I think the reason Biden's being
quiet is Trump and others are already
saying Biden's orchestrating the entire
thing you know Democrats Biden George
sort they're all orchestrating the
entire thing when Joe Biden was asked
about it he just said I'm not going to
comment he is making it he what I think
Biden doesn't want
is to make whatever Biden says is going
to be accused of being extremely
politically biased people are going to
read into it that Biden was somehow
involved or whatever I love that listen
this is law enforcement looking at
evidence and bringing charges in New
York City it should have nothing to do
with Joe Biden and I like that Biden's
not saying a word the right by the way
Rodney Ronald is triggered by this I saw
a fox news report the other day where
they said look at Biden's just smiling
and not saying anything even not saying
anything is angering them I think it's
the right move and I think Biden's smart
for keeping his mouth shut for now
so he gave you thanks for that question
man okay your soul keep up the good work
all right Ronald from Illinois thank you
so much for the call very much
appreciate it yeah if anybody thinks
Biden should be talking about it let me
know I just I just don't see it let's go
to Andrew from California Andrew from
California welcome what's on your mind
hi um the first time caller long time
listener thank you uh kind of nervous
but um I'll power through it yeah you're
doing great so much
I just wanted to discuss with you about
the
when dealing with irrational like Trump
trump supporters yeah
what is the calculus because I've seen a
lot of progressive hosts handle it both
ways where they're like very patient and
uh charitable innocence versus like just
steamrolling them and then just hanging
up on them and not letting them talk
like for example for with you you had
that guy who uh you guys were getting
into like the semantics of like Trump
not being allowed with the nuclear codes
yeah and I feel like you took like a
charitable uh approach which I agree I
agreed with you but I felt like you
could have been more charitable
but I I don't know I'm just a schmuck I
don't know uh so listen it depends what
you want to achieve right I mean my
point with that guy that was Bobby Polo
the reason I gave that guy so much time
and so much leeway was he was one of
those guys who showed up in our super
chats during a live stream and said I
want to debate you and you won't debate
me and you won't give me time and blah
blah blah blah and so the point I was
trying to make was I'll gladly give you
time and I'll allow you every
opportunity to make your point and the
guy had 10 minutes and he quite
literally wasn't able to make a single
point and the point of that was less
about telling him he was wrong about
every particular issue he didn't even
bring up an issue that was the funny
thing the guy was desperate to debate
and couldn't actually even hold a
conversation so that was more about like
these people who were big tough guys on
the internet who want to debate then you
give them a chance they make no sense
they might as well be speaking a foreign
language in other situations on somebody
who comes at me with a particular issue
that they're wrong about then it would
be less about being as charitable as
possible and more about showing them
that they're actually wrong on the issue
does that make sense Andrew like it
depends on the situation
yeah I guess it's I don't know I guess
sometimes I I
prefer the more charitable approach I
just feel like maybe then there'd be
more of a chance of
connection but maybe that's just wishful
thinking no I think on balance you're
right it just with that particular guy
you're thinking of it went nowhere
because there was no substance to it you
know we could he wouldn't even
understand what my position was and yet
he still tried to tell me I'm wrong but
it's like dude you don't even understand
what I'm saying how can we go forward
here
I felt like with the nuclear weapons
issue which I think was like the one
that kind of was
ballooned yep I felt like you could have
been a little bit more like
okay when you make a black and white
statement where I don't think Trump
should be around nuclear weapons which
is ridiculous the president must you
know have
you know access to that I just think
that he would be very irresponsible I
didn't feel like you
said it in a way where he was going to
be able to receive that and digest it
and maybe understand that I mean well I
think you're right I don't think he was
going to be able to understand what I
was saying but the extent to which I
just have to keep restating it I think
you know he he had a bunch of time and
he wasn't getting it so it was just time
to move on you know
okay all right one last comment uh bring
back Jimmy from Philly haven't heard
from him for years Andrew it's crazy
I just miss his voice fair enough maybe
we can find an impersonator all right
Andrew thanks so much for the call
thank you all right there goes Andrew
with a very very powerful declaration
let's go to Dariel from Texas Dario from
Texas welcome what's on your mind today
oh hi David uh oh all right uh sorry I'm
just kind of nervous okay so my question
it pertains to the debate about like
Trump's indictment I wonder if it's
gonna help uh uh I just saw a recent
poll from like rasmusen I believe that
shows Biden trailing both Trump and
DeSantis so just so you know rasmussen's
not a good pollster so I tend not to
look at Rasmussen what I would do is
maybe look at an average of recent polls
or look at like the 538 recent polling
and just look at posters rated A and B I
I just don't think rasmussen's a good
pollster but that but it may not matter
for the question you're going towards
all right yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
want to put a light damage away on a
single pole no but anyways when it comes
to like Trump's indictment yeah uh like
like it could help him in the primary
but I still have a hard time seeing a
Highlander general you know like Trump
he needs like Independence right and
like moderate Republicans you know to
win the general not just a MAG of bass
so my question to you is when it comes
to need indictment what actually went
over like independent and swing voters
or could actually like hurt him in a
general I think in the general I don't
think the index so for now we're talking
just about the one indictment right if
there's a different indictment in
Georgia we would have to evaluate the
charges the implications what that's
going to do to Trump's ability to
campaign and then I'll give you an
updated opinion based only on the arrest
and indictment in New York City with the
34 felonies I do believe it helps Trump
in the primary it helps Trump because
nobody's been talking about Ron DeSantis
since the Trump arrest happened and so
publicity Wise It's been better for
Trump than DeSantis I think it has
activated some of Trump's base
um and so I do think Trump has helped in
the primary by this New York City
indictment I don't think it gets him a
single new vote in the general and so
there I think it actually hurts him
oh gosh okay yes yes I was only
wondering because I remember during
during the during a like the 2016
election like James Comey like he
released a letter on like Hillary
Clinton and and like Hillary like she
was never indicted never arrested but
yet you know but yeah it didn't help her
at all in the general elections so so
I'm just here wondering you know Trump
was actually indicted or arrested yes
and is likely to indicted again in
future cases I just have a hard time you
know seeing how people outside the mag
of Base because it has like a w or for
good for Trump I agree with you 100 and
honestly if they really believed it was
good they'd be less angry and they'd be
happier than they are so I don't buy it
for a second I think your analysis is
spot on
oh gotcha okay uh yes uh like like
that's all I want to ask you like thank
you for taking my call all right Dario
from Texas great to hear from you we're
gonna go to a break I'm sorry I wasn't
able to get to everyone but we will take
calls again back with much more right
after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into Friday feedback
so many different messages coming in
continuing for all sorts of different
reasons and I want to have an
opportunity here to go over some stuff
with people in the audience one of the
things that I love about my audience is
you all don't forget about gun safety
just because it's been like a little
while since the last major mass shooting
now in the United States we have
individual shootings
we have mass shootings and then we have
major mass shootings major means like it
actually makes National headlines it's a
crazy country where we actually have
mass shootings every day but most of
them don't make National headlines okay
you all keep your eye on the ball even
when there hasn't been a major national
mass shooting for a little bit
here's a very interesting uh YouTube
comment which says David as a
law-abiding citizen who owns several
firearms that I use for sport shooting
and hunting there's something no one has
been able to explain to me how is it
that the Federal Government Can
Implement and enforce a national ban on
fully automatic weapons and shot off
shotguns but is unable to do the same
for semi-automatic Firearms seems to me
that every mass shooting in recent
history has involved a semi-automatic
firearm a ban on semi-automatic Firearms
would not violate the Second Amendment
and as a matter of fact could we argued
that it speaks directly to the
well-regulated militia aspect of the
Second Amendment what are your thoughts
well the answer is of course you could
ban semi-automatic weapons but there
isn't Congressional support to do it
this I'm not going to pretend that I can
cite every law on which the current
status quo is based okay that that I'm
making that very very clear but the
National Firearms Act of 1930 before
is very much if not the only reason
again I want to defer a little bit to
possibility it is a huge part of the
reason why fully automatic machine guns
are not legal and it's because of how
they are classified and it goes back to
the National Firearms Act of 1934
and other elements of law there have
been votes in the House of
Representatives as to whether to ban
semi-automatic weapons as well but these
votes have not succeeded at a time when
you could also get a vote to succeed in
the Senate and have it signed by the
president this is absolutely something
that could be done as this viewer points
out it wouldn't violate the Second
Amendment now it's just a matter of
where we draw the line do we we most
people agree that shoulder mounted RPGs
are on the band side and should be not
not they agree they are they agree they
should be on the ban side we have the
National Firearms Act of 1934 when it
comes to fully automatic machine guns
just a matter of where we draw the line
the the answer for why semi-automatic
weapons aren't banned is that they there
is not the political will to actually do
it it's that simple
um and I don't know maybe it will change
but you're absolutely correct that a
disproportionate number of these major
mass shootings are committed at the
hands of such a semi-automatic weapon so
Scott commented on YouTube says David
I've been watching on your uh been
watching your content for a couple of
years love what you do love your
presentation style and the way you do
you think about things you help me to
craft my own ideas about how to engage
with my trumpster dad and still allow
room for Grace knowing he has been
brainwashed by Fox that's sad I hope you
weather this storm I'm in Georgia I'm a
retired 20-year U.S Army infantry senior
NCO I am a combat veteran of Iraq and
Afghanistan I don't really know if it's
even possible or helpful but if there's
anything I can do to provide for you and
your loved ones protection and safety I
would do it for free
well I might ask for a dry place to
sleep and food if it's too far from home
thank you sir and thank you for your
service and we are weathering the storm
you know it is upsetting to many of the
in in the hate mob I know they're
Furious because they keep writing to me
they really thought they were going to
get me canceled over the tweet from now
a couple weeks ago they really did
and they saw that we came out of it with
tens of thousands more YouTube
subscribers and the website generated
over a thousand new paid subscribers and
messages of support from celebrities and
elected officials and listen anyone with
half a brain knows what I'm talking
about anyone with half a brain knows I'm
not going to blame kids who were killed
for being killed we blame our elected
officials and we blame the shooters
that's who we blame
um and aspects of the society that have
gone wrong but I really appreciate that
and we are getting through it and it's
been crazy but we are doing what we can
jack commented on YouTube and said I
used to be a conservative I switched
because of people like Pac-Man and Kyle
kolinsky keep doing what you're doing
right now David they only hate the Tweet
because you are 100 correct
conservatives are more angry over your
Tweet than they are that kids were
murdered it's a useful distraction if
you're mad at me and some of them still
are if you're mad at me
you don't have to talk about the fact
that you don't want to do a damn thing
about guns one other message along these
lines this one's from Scott this one
might be fake it's funny though it might
be real I used to be a conservative for
over 40 years Pacman changed that Trump
changed that I put in the paperwork to
become a Democrat and I've never been
happier I even lost weight hanging
around left Wingers you know this may be
a joke I genuinely don't know what's so
funny about it is obesity is
dramatically higher in red States I mean
we it's not about make everything
political there was recently a study
about life expectancy at Birth in the
deep blue areas of the country and the
Deep Red areas of the country obviously
you have to take economics into account
big big part of this but you are likely
to live much longer
if you are born and live in blue areas
it's it is an incredible thing that we
have going on in this country where
political allegiance and the allegiance
of state government has such an impact
on every aspect of our lives really
incredible stuff Raymond emailed me
and said just to comment from an average
Joe I think this is super interesting
and also very depressing Raymond said
was just watching Friday feedback and
heard your advice about debating people
online I'm pretty good at it probably
because I'm 64. I've been a politics
junkie since age 16 used to skip school
so I could stay home and watch the
Watergate hearings in the last two years
I've debated at least 40 magas into
silence I set traps for them by writing
things I know they'll agree with and
then pointing out how the sum of those
beliefs add up to the opposite of the
point they're trying to make then they
go quiet they'll never admit it and
they'll never admit I'm right in the
moment but their silence signals their
capitulation but then it occurred to me
there are 70 million more of them out
there and suddenly those victories feel
pretty Hollow it's demoralizing this one
hits guys this one hits as I've said
before
we can spend hours trying to show these
people the errors in their ways
and sometimes we'll succeed
and then you remember 70 million people
voted for Trump and you realize what we
are up against so an inspiring message
from Raymond in the sense that he he has
clearly figured out a way to do it
but then you remember there's 70 million
of them and then then what then where do
we go this is the whole retail versus
wholesale strategy thing that's often
discussed the ways to achieve rapid
social change often are to enforce them
via dictatorship which I'm against I
know Trump's enamored with all these
dictators but I'm not
so then you say well then how do you do
it
and it is very slow change over long
periods of time focusing on education
focusing on media literacy
extremely extremely difficult to do
Daniel wrote in and says I'm evil this
is still like the sort of stuff that's
coming in based on the tweet from a
couple weeks ago Daniel says David you
are evil I saw the Tweet you mocked
murdered Christian children I am sorry
for you your parents failed and you were
troubled on the inside May somehow you
find peace your hatred must be a serious
burden yeah no that's not really it I am
disgusted by our elected officials who
send thoughts and prayers and do nothing
else that's basically it it's not about
evil it's not about troubled it's not
about finding peace it's not about any
of it but uh these folks won't stop guys
they they keep emailing
here's George all right this is
something I think you guys are going to
enjoy
George Rhoden and said David considering
how small the trans population is
worldwide why do you spend so much time
covering trans issues please tell me how
to cancel my membership thank you George
um I've told you guys before about what
I call unsubscribe trolls these are
people who write to me and they say
David
I was just about to become a paid member
and then you said X and now I'm not
going to David I've been a subscriber
for five years but now that you said why
I'm canceling I looked up George George
was last a member in 2020.
and since 2020 this is why why we file
all of our messages sometimes law
enforcement needs them but this is
another reason why since 2020 George has
written to me
16 times
saying he's going to cancel his
membership because I said X and then
because I said why and then because I
said Z in fact when I look this up
it's like who has time to do this stuff
George wrote To Me
uh back in November
and said you're not talking about the
CCP enough
I'm canceling and then George wrote to
me in this so there's so many of these
it's hard to find all of them
uh oh God when was this George wrote to
me in May
and said they need to do something about
smart fencing at schools and you're not
talking about it and I'm going to cancel
okay the point here is
George has written to me 16 times saying
he's going to cancel
since he was last a member folks I've
said it before and I'll say it again the
freedom that I get
from being supported by individual
members is that no one person can come
in and tell me cover this or don't cover
it or whatever the case may be that's a
great thing and I will continue covering
what I think makes sense why am I
covering the trans issue more than the
prevalence of trans people in the
population very good question the reason
is because the American right wing has
now started devoting way too much of
their time to making the lives of trans
people a living hell and so when I see a
group being targeted
unfairly I come to their defense as soon
as the mob leaves trans people alone I
will be able to move away from that
issue so that's why George all right my
friend best of luck with all of it send
in your emails info davidpackman.com
YouTube comment tweet Facebook we pull
these from all over the place and uh
yours might be featured next week
fantastic bonus show for you today sign
up at joinpakman.com don't miss it
extraordinary stuff
foreign